........
In this video I will explain several examples of quadratic equations
It is in fact a special formula, and it is also
You will be ready for the next video, and we will talk about
Complete the box
So let me show you what I'm going to talk about
Let's say I have 4 x +1 squared-8
Is equal to zero
Now, on the basis of everything they have done so far, perhaps
I used to beat, then divide by 8, from
The hard you will get here, then try to analyze it to its causes
After that, we will get Q
Minus something else equals zero
And then you will say, Ooh, one of these things must be equal
Zero, so it can be this or that
We will not do this this time, because it is possible
See something exciting here
We can solve it without factors
How can we do that?
What will happen here if we add 8 for both parties
Next to this equation?
On the one hand equation will become 4 x 1
Squares, and the existing octets will be deleted
On the other hand, the 8 will be positive
Now, what can we do on both sides of the equation?
This is something strange, Vanilla!
Solution equation
This is not a hard fact
We can take the two-sided box, next to the equation
We can also take the square root
So 4 o +1, I just took the square root for both parties
We took the square root of both sides, of course
You want to take the square root of positive and negative
Because 4x + 1, it can be the square root positive for 8, or
We can take the negative square root for 8
So 4 + 1 is positive or negative
Square root of
Instead of 8, let me type the 8 on the 4 hit 2
We all know that the 8 is also written as well, and it is clear that the square root
For 4 x +1 squared is 4 o +1
So we can take 4 x 1 equals .., we can take the common factor out, the 4
Or square root for 4, equal to 2, which is equal to or positive
Negative hit 2, the square root of 2, right?
The square root of the 4 quadratic root multiplication of 2 is the same as Ka
Square root of 4 multiplied by square root of 2, positive or
The negative square root of 4, is 2 there
Now, we can see market equations, with
This is positive or negative 2 multiplied by 2 squared
But it is not like that
This is actually two numbers here, and we are like you
Together we solve two equations
We can write this 4 x 1 equal to positive 2
The square root of 2, or 4 x 1 is equal to minus 2 multiplied by
Square root of 2
This sentence is equal to the one here
Because we have a positive and negative here, for the phrase (or)
Let me solve them all at once
So if you subtract 1 from both ends of this
Equation, what do I have?
At the left end, I only have 4 o
At the right end, I have - a fact you can not
Mathematically, I mean, you can do it if you have
Calculator, but I'll make it a plus-or-so
Minus the square root, or 2 multiply the square root of 2
This is a 4x value
If we do it here, as two separate parameters, with the same idea
We subtract 1 from both ends of this equation, get 4 x
Equal to 1 plus 2, multiply the square root of 2
This equation, subtract 1 from both ends
4 x equals -1 minus 2, multiply
Square root of 2
This sentence here is equal to the fullness of these two
The sentences
Now, the last step, we just divide both parties on 4, then
You divide both sides by 4, and you get x equal
1- Plus or minus 2, multiply the root
Quadratic of 2, on 4
Now, this sentence is fully equal to
Divide each one of these on 4, and you get x equal
1 plus 2, multiply the square root of 2, at 4
This is one solution
The other solution is that x equals -1 plus
2 for root 2, all divided by 4
This sentence and these two sentences are equal
If you want, I encourage you to - to replace one
This, just to be confident that something
Strange such sentences can be a solution
For an easy and simple equation like this
So let's make up for it again
4 hit x, or 4 hit 1-, plus 2 for root 2 on 4
1 squared, minus 8 equals 0
Now, all these 4 are deleted, and you have left 1-
Plus 2 for root 2, plus 1, squared, minus
8 equals 0
These 1 and 1 are deleted, then
We will have 2 root 2 squared, minus
8 equals 0
Then what will you have here?
So when you are squaring these, you get 4 hit 2, minus 8 is
Equals 0, that's true
8 minus 9 equals 0
When you try this, you will get the same
the answer
Let's start with another one that is similar to it
Remember, these are special forms where we get
Quadratic equations of our equations (mathematical equations)
We will see that the quadratic equation is fully
Is a fact derived from such a theory, because you
A fact can transform any quadratic equation
To a whole square equal to something else
We'll see that after two videos from now
But let us prepare with vision
Such a thing
So let's say that you have a minus x minus 10 x plus 25
Equal to 9
Now, again your suspicions - which are not bad thoughts
You will be subtracting 9 from both parties
You'll get 0 at the right end, but before you do this
Let's check these out quickly, let's just say, these
Maybe a whole square of a double-edged equation?
And you will see - well, the two numbers that if hit (weakened)
I get 25 positive, and when I add them I get minus 10?
I hope you jump (appear) to you minus 5
So this sentence here is a minus 5 minus x 5 minus
The left-hand tip will be shaped like a minus 5 square all
The right side remains 9
The truth I want to emphasize
I do not want this to spoil all the training you have received
On the factors yet
We can do this when there is a whole box
If you get, we decrease 3 hit (positive 4) and this will be
Equal to 9 This will be the end
You can not do anything
Based on this
Just because this square is full we can now say o minus
5 All squared is equal to 9, and then we can take the root
Quadratic for both parties
So we can say minus 5 is negative or positive 3
Add 5 to both ends of equation and get equal q
5 positive or negative 3, or x equals - what is 5 plus 3?
Well, o may be 8 or x may be equal to 5 minus 3, or x
Equals 2
Now, we could have done this quadratic equation
The traditional way, the way it is
We wanted to do it
What will happen if we subtract 9 from each
Both ends of the equation?
You will get a squared minus 10 o
And what is 25 minus 9?
25 minus 9 is 16, and this will be equal to zero
Here, this will be a traditional transaction equation
The type we saw in the previous video
The two numbers, which when you take the product of their multiplication, get
Positive 16, and when you collect them you get minus 10?
Maybe minus 8 and minus 2
Jump to your thinking
Then we will get an x ​​minus 8 minus x 2 equals 0
Then x equals 8 or x equals 2
This is the fun thing about algebra: you can do this
In two different ways, as long as you do them
Algebraically true, you will not get
Different answers
At some level, if you know this, this is easier
Because you do not need to do this little trick in your mind
In terms of, multiply the numbers if you hit them
You'll get 16, and when you collect them, you get minus 10
Here, you will say, well, these are minus 5 - I think you are
You have to do it
You should say, 5 hit 5 is 25, and negative 10
Are minus 5 plus (minus 5)
So I'll pull it off, you have to do it
With that little trick in your mind
So let's get to each other
Let's have one of these, just to make ourselves
Ready and ready here
So, let's say that we have x squared plus 18 x plus 81
Equals 1
So again, we can do it in two ways
We can subtract 1 from both parties, or we can discover that
These are the plus 9 plus x 9 plus
Here, 9 hit 9 are 81, 9 plus 9 are 18
So we can write our equation on the basis of X plus 9
All square equals 1
We take the square root for both ends, you get x plus 9
A positive or minus a square root of 1
It is 1
So Q equals - subtract 9 from both parties - negative 9
Negative or positive 1
This means that this can be equal to minus 9 + 1
Is minus 8 or o can be equal to minus 9 minus 1
Which is negative 10
Again, you can do it the traditional way
You can subtract 1 from both parties and you will get
On a squared plus 18 x plus 80 equals 0
You will say, 8 hit 10 equals 80, 8 plus 10
Equals 18, and you get x plus 8 hit x plus 10 equals 0
And then you get x it can be equal to minus 8, or x
Is equal to minus 10
This is a good setting
Now, I think we are ready to address (solve) the completion of Quadrature
..........